hello there so I'm Sam I don't know why
I'm here really I'm a musician I'm come
to talk to programmers how many of you
can program which is cool right okay so
normally want to give a talk most people
don't put the hands up because I'm
talking to children typically or
teachers or artists or anybody else
really and I think actually what I'm
going to say for the next bit of time
could possibly be useful for you as well
because how many of you have ever been
to a party that's pretty good I'm quite
excited so most of you not all of you I
must say however you try to have a
conversation about your work at the
party yeah right how many times that
gone really well ya know some some time
okay were the parties programmer parties
probably the answer's yes and I think
this is a problem if you're a guitarist
you go to a party say and people say
what's your name you say I'm I'm John
the guitarist he's and they say what do
you play see obviously the guitar I'm
John the guitarist and they then will
talk to you for quite a long time about
guitars about music and they'll be able
to find an interest but when you say I'm
John the programmer I'm Kate the
programmer that often kills a
conversation flats and it's the problem
for our society in general because we
need to find ways to actually engage
more people in programming not make it
an opaque iddin thing but find out ways
that we could actually engage a broader
sense of society and hopefully have that
conversation where people actually call
you're a programmer and they actually
want to talk to you right and I think
the biggest problem we have today is
that programming is typically used for
for money-making companies how many of
you work for money making companies all
of you right okay that that's not a bad
thing necessarily but it is a bad thing
for programming I think because it's not
very diverse we're not using programming
in as many areas as we possibly could
now you could obviously say the same for
music you can go to a music conference
and say how many of you make music for
adverts probably quite a few musicians
would put it put them hand up because
that's going to make them their bread
and butter money they're going to be
able to afford to buy their children
food but a lot of musicians don't
necessarily want to just make money for
adverts or money for organizations or
companies or lyft music now they want to
make their own music and so what would
be the equivalent of making your own
programs and
making room own code that's gonna
actually be interesting exciting to the
world that's beyond stuff for companies
and I really think that it's really
important to say that and because if you
go into a school and tell kids you need
to learn to code because you can be a
professional programmer that's just a
ludicrous starting point it's like
saying to kids you need to learn to play
sports become a professional sports
person because that's not why why you
learn sports you learn sports because
why you learn sports because it's good
for your body it's good if your
well-being in your minds it's good for
teamwork there's lots of positive
attributes of sports that are not being
a professional sports person so why on
earth do we have the same association
with learning code and and companies
it's just there's been nuts
and I think that's the same problem for
going into parties because as soon you
see a program you're basically saying
I'd like to talk to you about business
you know business apps or the
scalability of this large scale with a
little business business business and I
think that people don't want to talk
about that so much the more much rather
talk about music or culture or things
that they're excited about the influence
then and I think that it's a tragedy
that we haven't got a ton of things we
could talk about immediately that come
from programming because programming can
influence society massively it does
already from a business perspective but
there's so much more we could do know
that we could internally have good fun
doing but also could help us to engage a
broader audience a more diverse audience
not just children but everybody and get
everybody doing a bit of programming
just like everybody does a bit of sports
is not everyone's professional sports
people but everyone has a bit of a go
playing a bit of tennis or a bit of
football um does it make sense right and
I think that's really hard to get
started because if you say to people so
says to you like kid might come up and
say I want to learn how to make a game
you like cool let's do it what would you
like to do it like well and their minds
whirring you like cogs are going I want
to be on a horse back I want a hill and
they like they've got a Zelda in the
head I'm looking over the landscape and
I can see it in the distance as this
castle I'm gonna go and read it and when
I actually bring on and it find all my
soldiers and bring together as well I
can do your circle that can be the
castle and we can have triangles linked
because obviously you're not going to be
able to make
people a game no you and it unit kids in
a couple of afternoons you can really
limit yourself by doing something on
processing or some very simple canvas
drawing or something needs to get
started which when we were kids if you
all similar ages to me what have been
great I love moving shapes around a
screen it was brilliance
no but people's expectations are
drastically changed so we have to find
ways that are not just about programming
but are about things which actually
impact people and they care about and so
there I think there many other things
there other than games which can help
this conversation um the first one is
this thing called music yes right music
so what I want to do is I want to think
about how do we actually find ways to
engage kids and everybody else that's
meaningful to them but also how allows
us to both answer some really deep and
technical and interesting computer
science problems as well as get them
excited about the basics of code can we
do all those things at the same time now
I I hesitate to talk to people like
yourselves because one of the first
times I actually spent talking about
music at a computer programmers industry
focus an event like this was in the
first Clojure cange
in the States and I've been working on
the system called overtone which is a
closure music system and the friend
called Jeff Jeff rose and we we built
the system it was cool we've been
invited to go and give a talk at the
close of college I gave a talk book
before hands or listening to these
people talk about some event system
they'd built and some I in a banking
thing and they'll talk about sending
these events back back and forth and I
was overhearing them and I walked over
and said ah I recognized that problem
and they said Oh what do you mean and I
suggested well in our system we were
doing this and I said oh what's your
system and I said it's a music system
they walked off right so I think there's
actually as a problem also when I Suz I
used words like music and arts are
people sort of trivializing what it what
it is but let me just put it in
perspective what I've written what I'm
going to show you is a soft real-time
concurrence deterministic live coding
with strong sense of time using sort of
a lot of logical clocks system that kids
can program that
can program let me just put in a
perspective there's an brooded cool tech
in here and I'm very happy to spend a
long time as you need to talk about it
offline afterwards about any aspect so
you want to talk about but this is the
system it's entirely free it's open
source and you download it you click on
these buttons for Windows Mac Raspberry
Pi and Linux if you have a rush leap is
already installed by defaults and when
you download it you get something like
this which is a text editor and you type
coding in it doesn't work because it
doesn't make any sense but um this is
this is a critical thing because if you
say to people how to get started they
ask you and you say we're not gonna do
the game let's take some music but for
the first thing you've got to say is
it's in download Emacs or download
IntelliJ and Java and maven and whatever
that there's a lot of work right and and
most people are just going to stop at
that certainly my mum is not gonna
install maven right there's your mum
gonna so it could I'd be cool I like to
hang out with her if she wants to and so
the thing that you've got to find out I
know also teachers are not gonna store
movie so you've got to think about what
is the simplest way to get started so
sonic PI you just open it up and you've
got an editor or ready to go and you can
just type words in and you can try words
in and you can press the Run button and
you can doesn't make any sense so you
also need to know what that's the first
word to play right is that's the word
play choose that and you get a beep very
quite beep there we are so this is your
first program with Sonic PI it's very
simple you write the word play you
choose a number you know what they mean
at all but numbers are pretty cool on
they know who likes numbers what do
numbers do nobody knows you're all
programmers you want professional
programmers they go up and they go down
do you not know that well that's super
useful remember that so the cool thing
about the world is there's lots of other
things which can go up and can go down
right have you got anything which can go
up and go down you can model it with
numbers unless you must know this come
on right lengths and distances and time
and pitch are all things which is which
you can model with numbers and this is a
way to get started the kids you talk
about abstraction you say well we got
this number it can map onto
things in the real world what's the
thing in the real world you care about
with music how high or how low the note
is and so instantly kids can start
playing and writing the uncouthness and
then you say okay let's let's play a
melody that's no play note 60 in the
note 65 and that might surprise some of
you programmers out there I don't know
if you think that's an imperative
language or a functional language or
something in between it's kind of
declarative at this point actually
because what we're describing is two
notes to be played and we're not talking
about time so although time is implicit
in all programming languages it's do
instruction X then do instruction Y for
imperative and this is kind of what's
happening if you notice on the right
hand side here it's very small let's
make that slightly larger did a little
look at time zero we played both these
notes concurrently at the same time as
sample accurate at the same time so two
144 thousand one hundredths of a second
these are started exactly the same time
so this is cool we can do chords and
it's played like another one lovely so
we want to make a melody we need one
more command lovely who's enjoying that
now I'd know about you but to me this is
the starting point for a beautiful
conversation because if you think about
it deeply this is pretty much all of
western music I mean it's it's a broad
claim but it is most of it right what is
western music it's which note to play
when to play it you can make any melody
by knowing which know to play and when
to play any bassline and each Zajkowski
any Daft Punk right and kids can do this
too and it's this shouldn't be a
surprise like logo had the similar kind
of properties logo you have pen down pen
up rotate forwards and with those
commands you can draw any picture okay
with these two commands you can make any
melody and kids do and they'll go
playing stick play state-based even I
had my six-year-old niece she was on
line a hundred you know it's like that's
an amazing melody well dishes and I'm
not finished yet she was still going and
so this like this to me is really
important not to be able to just be able
to do exciting sophisticated things with
programming languages but you'll be able
to do very simple things and have the
very simple things be a pro
ball and simple and all of you tonight
can go home and do this oh I've got
multiple goals they're giving this talk
one of those goals is to try and get
some of you to have a go at doing this
tonight now I say that because it's
after the closure conference I mean
although I had that negative
conversation as people and they were
like whatever music I got a standing
ovation and I gave the talk and rich
Hickey Karen you're badass not oh that's
amazing
and then all these people went away and
downloaded it of course they all had
maven and Emacs and what sort of stuff
and and so they could get overtone and
make music with it well they couldn't
because the starting point to Overton
was design you know synthesizer and
obviously nobody knows how to design
synthesizers really it's a whole set of
skills and so under walking to my room
late at night been really excited about
the talk had given and all this crazy
sounds are coming from all the hotel
rooms which is great to hear I was
really encouraging but nobody got
further than that because it was too
hard to move on so although these people
were steeped in the technologies that
had used and so they could get started
they couldn't do anything more than make
a whole horse sound so I'm hoping that
I'm going to convince you that from here
to being a professional DJ is they're
just it's not that hard and just a
matter of practice and what will get
there so alright do you think you could
DJ with this so far no but you could
make any melody that's already a good
start what else can you do right so this
is cool because when you're teaching
kids out of code it's I don't think it's
about what programming concerts are
there and what languages are there are
and what it's about what do what do you
want to do and what of what you want to
do can be achieved right
and to this point you ask kids what do
you want to do and they might say well
that's just sounds rubbish that beep and
so then you say okay well we've got
different sounds that's let's play with
different sounds of it let's change the
synthesizer to diesel
so we can play a really different kind
of different sound there's a lot of fun
now each of these sounds that might
sound very simple but down here in the
documentation
each of these black things is a knob
fire control and now if you think about
them in terms of synthesizers these kind
of guys
that's okay far out this when you buy
with a synthesizer the first of all is
stupidly expensive and they're massive
so you can't really take them around
very easily so if you want to do a gig
with one of these it's it's like you've
got to have a truck and but all these
things here these are controls you can
tweak and modify and play with which is
huge fun and so and they will all modify
the kind of sounds which are produced
which then you can sort of tune them
into your own sounds in sonic PI each of
these controls here is one of those
knobs and sort of physically turning an
actual actual potentiometer you just
write the numbers you want to you want
to do it and if you don't write any
numbers like here there's no controls
here there's a bunch of defaults which
get executed so you just think them as a
hashmap of key value pairs where the
values are defaults but you can override
them arbitrarily and there's just huge
funds let's play that so if I use synth
profits I can play you know 260 or could
even actually if you know a bit about
music you can use actual music notation
it can change the release time to be 8
and one of the only options in in the
profit is cut off meeting note
representing the highest frequencies
allowed to be present in this hour these
are things you can explore you don't
need to know about them but they're fun
to play with so what does cut-off do
let's try cut-off of 70
they implicitly is the currency notes
are overlapping so every time anything
goes pink I'm creating a new thread
that's right it's running at the same
time as everything else now I don't know
how many have you done multi-threaded
programming how many of you will be
prepared to take your multi-threaded
programming on stage in front of
thousands of people and perform with it
right that's how how sure I am in this
guy she's going to work pretty well so
you've got multi-threaded code running
the backgrounds and we're able to play
it simultaneously so this is actually
one way to work with sonic pies you just
have long-running things and just keep
laying on top of each other which is
huge fun so I can start
it's just by changing right so you this
might look crazy to you but it makes a
lot of sense to musicians so I'm taking
note each one and going seven semitones
down this is the kind of cool thing you
can do this program is called Ruby which
gets a lot of stick but actually is a
very flexible powerful language for
writing da cells in which is essentially
what this is so we're not we're not
carrying out performance this Ruby code
is running at human time right so it's
maybe spinning around maximum 32 times a
second all the audio synthesis has done
in C C++ by something called super
collider and it's essentially what the
Ruby code is doing is generating a set
of asynchronous messages to be sent over
the network to this route to the
superclass server which is then
executing them on time so my programming
language just cares about what to do and
when to do it and it roughly does it
around the right time and then sends it
ahead of time to something which can
then confine the control and do it
exactly the right time right so there we
go
so this is this is fun where do we go
next so well let's think about this does
this all another thing called sample
which load so so far I'm showing you
sandwich a which had computed in real
time from mathematics essentially it's
all those sounds with lots of look-up
tables of square waves and saw waves and
functions which take your number in and
output a number depending on what what
the function does the one could actually
add a low pass filter a high pass filter
so make it sound mellow or crunchy
these are just functions which take a
stream of numbers in and spit out a
stream of numbers out but you could also
take pre-recorded sounds I don't know
what a pre-recorded sound is it's an
interesting thing like because it's x
1.is weird things like that the airwaves
obviously vibrate in and out right and
that's what your ears hear and so when I
make a noise like a clap that foot
forces the air to be compressed and
decompressed and those waves hit your
eardrums obviously if you were able to
record those waves and and note where
the air pressure was and wrote it down
lots of times for seconds and then use
the same numbers to move something in
and out in exactly the same way that's
how you can reproduce a sound so the
thing which recalls the airway was the
microphone things reproduces the
airwaves is a speaker and so a sample is
really just a list of numbers about
where the microphone was in time now and
you just put that in a big file and even
send that to the sound card and it is
able to then send electronic signals to
the speaker which they're able
then move it in and out the same way so
this sample is just a list of numbers
list of floats and you couldn't create
those things by recording them with the
microphone and there's a bunch of
built-in ones so let's look at loop our
men it's just a pre-recorded sound of
whether John's relatives from the 60s we
can go back in time with sound which is
pretty cool but the cool thing about
numbers right and list of numbers it's
when we when you map a function over a
list right you don't have to do that in
one go you can do it slowly you can do
it quickly
obviously you don't think about that
when you're programming normally you
wanted to go as fast as possible but if
you think about in terms of music you do
care about the speed you go through
things because if you're computation is
faster you couldn't get a faster rhythm
right if your competition is sort of in
spurts and bursts your rhythm is not
going to be regular and in this case if
I walk through those numbers at the
normal rates
I hear the normal recording as it was
recorded rate no point five it takes
longer to get through the numbers it
also has an effect on the sound which as
a huge fund and so you can also do this
kind of thing like this
what's that backwards yeah exactly so
you walk through this backwards
[Music]
very funny fire you can take any so
these are the built-in samples where you
can record your own samples you can
download samples there needs to be raff
a FLAC OGG or gay or that's it that's
the support that's supported ones but
you have premium coded sounds and then
you start playing the back so what about
oh there's a bunch of other stuff you
can do one of the finished things to do
is as a programmer I see this this I can
hear this as sequence of drums being hit
one after another right that's like an
array of drum here with drum and which
time it was hit okay but of course
that's all encoded in this wav file this
audio file that you haven't got this
nice when was in to drum hit but you can
reverse engineer that you can do some an
analysis you can figure out when was the
onset when was it going from quite
allowed in the audio file and then get
those times and so we have that built in
we just say on sets 0 get the first run
second row you pull the drums out so you
can create a loop a sick fish on one
time
[Music]
lines of code yeah I could spend ages
picking apart this and it's a lot of fun
but I haven't really got the time to but
there's a bunch of interesting tech I
think which is going on here first of
all we've got this weird thing called a
live link right that's a weird thing
that's a special sama and weird loop and
let me explain what I mean by that so
kids will do this straight away loop to
sample whatever and acquire a c41 and
and they would like go and they would
have that and they would say right I
want to have that and some drums now how
many of you a programmers how many of
you know why there aren't drums not all
of you that's unfortunate
so we have this problem of the fact that
loops are infinite and once the program
gets into the loop it never gets out
does it it's like a black hole they're
rubbish loops I don't know why we ever
use them they're only useful if you're
like listening on a network socket
forever when else are they useful I
don't really know and so yeah the
program obviously just gets the end of
stays there forever so he never gets
down here so we have a problem and this
is that there and there this is to me
was super exciting because why yeah she
was really depressing because the kids
would say well why is it not playing the
same time you say well I know why but
unfortunately I can't tell you the
answer because you've got to wait to the
University because it's not on a
computer science curriculum we can't
cover this I'm sorry the teachers don't
have any time for its you we just we
can't do it and the kids are like want
to swear in your face obviously but
they're not allowed to it's all very
nice and and so this is a problem and so
you we can't teach concurrency we can't
teach threads in schools that there is
no time for it and the UK curriculum and
this is a problem because kids want to
do this they want to do this within a
few hours of playing with this kind of
system they immediately want to be able
to play the drums are the same
to the base that's what they want drums
and bass here what choirs and bass and
so the solution is to cheat you create
this single alive loop which when you
run it at times you need it have a
unique name live loop need to have a
unique name because these are now no
longer loops these are band members and
this is Petra and this is Jane right so
you just give them names need to be
unique so my band I can't have two
Fred's not allowed such a restriction
was he action fusing there's all their
interesting thing about what's going on
here because concurrency is already
pretty hard isn't it the game thing
brights I mean concurrency is easy but
actually coordinating state across
threads that's the tough bit and and
then this is this has got another
problem because I don't care just about
playing the same time we don't care
about coordinating state to though this
is not happening in this particular case
but we will do that later what we also
care about is them running at the same
time actually at the same time not not
at the same time but on time with each
other like a bands placed here there's
no point having their bass guitar
playing at the same time as a drummer if
they're not playing at the same rhythm
or the same tempo right it's not good
enough that they're both playing
simultaneously they have to be playing
in time with each other and if I were to
change this to something shorter and
play notes Eve 3y or something
release time short not very nice listen
to what you can totally hear that in
time and and they really are properly in
time some particularly so the other
thing is live loop does is it allows you
to have not just concurrent things but
things in time and then the third thing
which is that which is the exciting bit
is
[Music]
some live coding and modifying the code
as it's running and the threads just
work timing is maintained knows no pause
or skips or anything it just clicks in
all the time on time so the live loops
give you this ability to modify them as
they're executing which is a starting
point for doing performances which is
huge fun right so that's this is where
as a programmer when you go into schools
and kids say well how do I do something
and the answer is you can't actually ask
programmers because it's such a magical
skill we have such an unbelievable skill
we have we can just go what screw that
I'm going to change these rules I'm
going to build something new no I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna listen to that I'm
gonna okay are we allowed to do loops
yes well I'm gonna create a new kind of
link with a live loop is that okay fine
and that's it the kid teachers don't
know we're doing concurrency don't need
to know if they do even better but if
they don't that's fine they don't need
to know about live coding that need to
know that that's actually incredibly
weird and difficult or not typical of
programming languages because kids have
fun and you can have fun and your
friends can have fun live coding it's
making sense to know yes right okay
right so where do we go from here
so there's a few other things let's have
a look at what we do don't we talk spend
more time talking about what you can do
with this or what we'll do I ask
questions or you've got me for a bit of
time so I'll just keep talking is this
fun is interesting about no idea I do it
all the time every single day so it's
normal for me oh yeah okay let's think
about other things so I've got this
thing called a keyboard
they don't heard of a keyboard before
it's not QWERTY right kids want to play
with this stuff you plug it in and you
want to be on look incidentally when you
plug it in I've got these events coming
in so I've got this weird immutable
event-driven pattern matching
deterministic thank you
inside sonic PI which I again it's
actually important to have all those
things because with music you care that
the code always produces the same music
that's deterministic and also I care
that when I play a chord all three notes
I'm able to write functions which are
able to ensure they're executed for each
of the three notes there's no race
conditions about your function handler
hasn't been created quickly enough for
you then to be able to observe that
event and then do something on the basis
of it so it's important to be able to
store the entire history of all the
events so that you can even play it back
and you mess around with it and treat it
like a data structure um so yes so here
we are I've got some keys that's so I'm
I know I'm connected which is pretty fun
what can I do with it so I could create
a live loop call foo I can synchronize
on and hear all the different things I
can synchronize so all the live loops
and sounds that can synchronize them so
you could synchronize between live loops
which is really important but also I can
synchronize all these MIDI events so
I've got this note on MIDI event so I'm
going to wait for that and I'm going to
play a sample bass drum boom notice
there's a delay can you hear that delay
[Music]
yeah half second delay no that's because
this system schedules everything ahead
of time right the reads the way I think
the fact I'm using this weird language
called Ruby which is got garbage
collection which is nuts right for a
soft real-time system any points they've
programmed say pause I'm gonna do some
cleaning you don't want it to do that
when you're making music like no to the
garbage collector and all sorts of
random stuff can happen so by executing
code sufficiently ahead of time and then
making sure that something else doesn't
have a garbage collector which is super
Clyde in this case we're able to
schedule things ahead of time and have
them work but of course in this case
because I'm getting an event in and then
sending it ahead of time that's adding a
latency that's a problem and so how do
we fix that well we can just turn the
latency off in for each independent
thread by saying use real time so this
thread now no longer schedule things
ahead of time
[Music]
but of course this data structure coming
in has this pattern here like a URL MIDI
his name the keyboards there's some MIDI
nonsense this is the note on note off
events and this the note is the
velocities so a moment I keep doing the
same thing but I can get the notes on a
velocity and extract those instead of
playing that I can play note n yeah so
now I've got a keyboard make it short
release so if you want that with maybe
some reverb you use this cool thing
called a anonymous function so ruby has
this really cool property where i can
say do ends at the end of any method and
it creates me an anonymous function
which then i again in my method i can
use i could execute and whenever I want
I am and rubyists tend to use this to
essentially setup and teardown contexts
before running arbitrary functions so in
this case I want to add some reverb so
what does that mean well in a guitar I
might get a guitar and plug into a
reverb pedal plug into a distortion
pedal plug it into my amplifier so here
I need to go magically runs the guitar
shocked by my reverb pedal great got it
and then plug it into my amplifier and
then make sure that any other
synthesizers which are created get
plugged into the reverb on the fly
that's what happens here so now we can
play run the code and the maybe you want
echo as well so very easy to add effects
and chain them right and if you are of
the of the I would I would say very
positive in cutting clinging of of being
a Lisp programmer just a good thing
you'll you'll make complete sender this
because unless everything goes from the
inside out and here we go from the
inside out as I play goes through the
echo goes to reverb and then go to the
outside context which is your speakers
so this way we can arbitrarily
stall these effects and now we have the
ability to play notes it makes sense
it's that fun and you can do the inverse
I haven't brought my all my kits but you
couldn't plug in external synthesisers
so external midi driven synthesizers and
we have a really nice Erlang scheduler
which does all the scheduling for us
which Joe Armstrong wrote of all people
and so that allowed you to bypass all
the garbage collection nonsense and
pausing of Ruby and and be able to shred
your things ahead of time and have them
get sent out on time you could also do
something like this live audio good name
and if you have that plug if you have a
guitar plugged into your audio card then
you would be here in the guitar right
and you do the same kind of stuff you
can add it with reverb or distortion and
so you can add effects to any external
instruments you can have a microphone
because in and have someone sync and
with that one line of code you've got a
clean signal but then with some effects
around if you say live or audio voice
you at least have a unique name and they
have like a reverb this now would if I
turn it on without it
obviously I'm with my computer having
the microphone attached to it listening
to the audios feedback but yeah this
will give you a voice with Reaper
there's a lot of fun now how long I've
got left maybe 10 minutes so that it's
important to point out that everything
I've shown you here though it might be
weird and new novel and I know confusing
perhaps or some people I can teach you a
10 year old child that's a really
important thing every single feature put
into Sonic pie
I've had to ask myself could I imagine
teaching this to a 10 year old child
which has been in the most insanely
difficult filter to put features past
there's lots of really exciting music
systems in the world out there today
with lots of really exciting music
features that are just for me so far too
complicated to consider how I might put
it into this kind of program that's
simple in a 14 year old child but it
turns out that when I can do that
I end up with system that actually
really works really
well for a very tired Sam 2:00 in the
morning we've had a couple of pints
who's about to perform - I know a bunch
of people in Munich which is what
happened last Saturday
and so actually a system which is simple
enough for school children the classroom
it turns out to be simple enough for you
to be performing with it hasn't got such
a cognitive load as and required to
really think so deeply about the
programming process it just allows you
to think more freely about the musical
outputs and the musical contexts and
then maybe there's a bunch of things to
extract them as talk from from your
perspectives but yeah I mean obviously
we talked about time about time and and
live coding but really about making the
language simple and not just simple to
write but simple to think about it
simple to reason about actually really
helps you get the core of the business
logic you try to write in my case the
business logic is music but it could be
anything I mean it could be it could be
your money making businesses and banks
and whatever lovely okay right so let's
let's think about what else we can do
we've got ten minutes that sound let's
have a play so we've got ability to
receive events we've got a village to
send events with mobility make sounds
that's what we need to make music so
let's think about it so if we can write
a live loop it's call it foo I can
that's thing oh we could do this that's
get the note and velocity let's get it
from our keyboard this one and then that
side now eight times let's play notes
and have a release time short and then
sleep just had the computer play the
notes for me and I'm just choosing which
now to play so I'm not having to worry
about timing this point include faulting
so like I can get you since D saw and
then I can have the
[Music]
got home got decode detune the fun one
be tuned 12 I can say it is a scale
minor enter time now the trick is I got
my right so gotta send your toosh always
end up in this parentheses around is
good because we like lists but we don't
want people to be scared about this and
lisps have fewer parentheses in Java
this is an immutable data structure
because scales are mutable they're
always going to be there in time they're
a mathematical description and here
we're picking through them this is a
really weird construction unit shredder
local speakers we understated our
structures but don't worry about that
too much
what do you think about what we're
treating this like an arpeggio going
round and round and round it and we're
playing it too thick so the question now
is how do we get the drums in right we
can easily do that with threads we can
add another thread you've got the kick
drum going but how do we make the drum
beat in time right because I know how to
start a new thread thread new will
create a new thread right but how do I
get a new thread to work at the same
time well we can try our best and click
a live loop course bar and sample bass
drum house for music one thing we do
know for a fact that our system this
system just does start every thread with
a riot logical time so you could stop
everything in starting but that's not
going to work in a performance is it
right so let's let's try and do this
again yes let's uncomment this
[Music]
so this is a critical aspect of this as
a system is that this is kind of like a
closure promise or a blocking construct
which will block the current thread
until event happens in this case the
event is the food live loop goes round
and so once it's gone round this can
start but it also shares across the
thread boundaries the actual logical
time so when this thread starts it has
inherited the timing mechanisms of this
thread so they are in exactly the same
time they have the same clock and so
that way you have concurrency but you
also have other threads to actually work
together in time with each other which
is huge fun so
[Music]
I'm trying to get to the point where
we're actually starting to make
something which might sound a bit like
music hopefully you could start to see
that and this is just 22 lines of code
quite a lot of white space we've got one
live loop making the drums one live loop
playing some samples are being
pre-recorded we're doing some cool
things with pattern matching over the
samples so we might have a whole
directory of samples a whole directory
of directories of samples musicians
we'll have gigabytes and gigabytes of
samples and so I'm able to search search
through them by doing string matches on
the file names regular expressions on
the file names or even lambda functions
on a set of candidate file names so you
really are able to then filter these
things out and so this case I'm finding
all of the EBIT bass samples this is a
director of samples which contained
their word string 122 that's the BPM to
contain the string C minor because all
my samples are well-named
choosing the first one and amplitude
amplifying it by 3 and then doing the
same thing but with a drum sample and
and I can even start to mess around this
[Music]
to discuss options
by even iteration and randomization
which is actually really important
points so I'm really serving about it at
all but I can talk about great lengths
that's that randomization is actually a
really useful tool if it's not random
right randomization that's really useful
if you're doing crypto right and then
you carry out entropy and you care about
it being properly random right and so
then you'll take pictures of lava lamps
on a big row right but what are you
making music it's quite nice to be able
to say frames and random notes but it's
not that useful if you like those notes
could you say well I'd like them again
sorry they were random you couldn't we
maybe you could find them again in ten
universes of time right if you were
looking enough to get exactly the same
results from the random stream but it's
unlikely umm and so actually what tends
to be really useful it's just to say
give me something which sounds random
but if I like it I like to be able to
reproduce it and so this this concert
here is a really nice way of doing
exactly that
because I can just
[Music]
use any sample
so I can completely change it around
[Music]
you
again it's a very simple thing to do so
this our pitch is able to know that it's
like a weird maths right if you get a
frequency in doublet that's an octave
always so any frequency doublet that's
an octave but then pitches on the piano
these sort of white and black notes it's
not really clear about which notes they
are you know that one ctoc is double a
frequency but depending on which culture
from which notes you have your
disposable and how you actually decide
what figures as are is completely
arbitrary currently in our Western weird
Western philosophy we've decided that we
have twelve notes between an octave and
we take an octave and divide it ecwid
istant across those twelve notes and so
this is able to then figure out well the
actual pitch offset a great modification
to this this sample to make it go up
there right number of semitones using
some crazy maths but again this is the
kind of thing that if you think about as
a programmer you can go and read the
material or read the resources read the
theory and then figure out how to make
it really simple for people to use so
again I don't want to have to think
about roots of the power 12 right when
I'm programming in a nightclub but I do
want to care about adding one or two or
three that's the easy thing to think
about right so makes a lot of sense cool
so this is making sense do you enjoy
this at all do you think you might want
to play with this I hope you do there's
a few things I want to finish off with
first of all is when you download it
where are we
yeah there we are you get an app like
this you actually end up with editor in
non-pro icon so they look like this so
the kids can read what's going on runs
play I always go for the pro icons to
look a bit slicker and then if you're
playing in a nightclub go for the dark
mode that's always good and you can turn
the Scopes on and off like you can move
these things around for it over there if
you want to or if here depending what
you're doing um and then how's it going
to crash no it's not
and then oh I have to have a bug man
computer ring it's going to die in a
second um I was to do that you could
also then asked how do you start
so that's unplugged and plugged in
and you click on the Help button that's
the information button and here we have
down here tutorial and you can you can
get this whole to throw thing you can
bring it out down here bottom section of
what sorry
so you haven't up this so I just clicked
on the help help button up here it's a
full screen and that just makes that
appear and you've got tutorial examples
maybe your apps like bigger than your
window if you double click on the title
bar thing you took will click on this
guy
maybe they'll stretch it the right place
if not I'll come and find you later
and the tutorials there and it's
basically a full book it's like over
35,000 words you'll teach you everything
you want to know about programming if
you know that already then you're gonna
be flying through that but I'll also
teach you everything you need to know
about the music required to make such
musical sonic PI so I'll teach you both
if you know about a little bit by either
you'll fly through if you know nothing
about either you should be fine and this
is again it's my promise to people who
are reading this as opposed to you and
promised your friends if there's like on
section a eight or section a nine there
was a thing you didn't quite understand
that's my fault not your fault
right and I'll do my best to fix that so
if you do find aspects of the tutorial
which don't make sense please tell me
and I apologize and I'll do my best to
fix it for the next person now it's too
late for you but for the next person I
shall be able to help so again and I
really hope that most of tutorial is
really really simple to understand so
you can learn it that way and then
there's these examples you can just
choose an example I like one of my
favorites ESRI raised cut and paste that
up here run it right off you go good
news
this is thing about them randomization
system right you heard that melody but
how has it been generated well we're
shuffling
a vector of numbers but we're shuffling
it the same way every single time so
that is to determine ISM actually is
really useful because if I send you this
code and your system does a different
randomization order than my system we're
going to hear a different melody and I'm
about be like this is a banging track
until that sadness is rubbish I just
purely because the randomization systems
made different choices and so what I
tend to do is I tend to shuffle things
but change the seed until I like it
that's a great way of exploring the
kinds of melodies you can choose in this
case the first one was actually quite
nice don't need to set the seed at all I
know I'm doing shuffling it and ticking
through the notes 64 times and adding
some effects and doing some crazy things
like this sleeping for - tea nuts might
be exciting to some programmers going
backwards in time which you can do
because you should having anything ahead
of time so within a buffer you can go
backwards and forwards in that and
there's a function called time warp
which will let you take any arbitrary
piece of code and push it forward or
backwards in time and it will execute a
different point in time playing our
sample and playing our bass drum simple
as that
and so we can just take something like
this
yet change the rate of this
change effects
my bathrobe
change it back
this is the kind of thing I will play in
a nightclub and people go crazy for it's
a lot of fun and watching the audience
and changing what you do based on where
they're liking it or not you can totally
do it can improvise the music on the fly
which is lots of fun and it's great to
be able to then to tell people write
comments a collab another beer please is
a good one I like to ask other ones is
like you thought programming can make
music you know people don't know that I
know and who thinks program is just for
business most people and I think it's
our job to actually not just make money
for business because that is an
important thing for some people in this
world and I'm terren and lots of people
eat meat that's totally fine right I'm
not gonna preach to you but also I think
that it's an opportunity for us to think
about how could we use our skills to
make the world a better place
and if your organization your company is
doing that yes right but if he isn't
thing to think about what else you could
do right where else could you get what
would be your sonic PI then you could
write because I'm sure most of you got
much better skills than me
I'm just very patient and just sit there
for a long time waiting for it to work
keeping on idea like this it's gonna
work it's going to work writing Windows
installers is exactly that kind of
nonsense but in reality is just it's
just a matter of patience so what could
you write they could actually make the
world a better place there isn't just
about making large organizations richer
and there and the stakeholders and that
that Richard is still and so they have
their fancy islands but we we're
struggling to try and figure out how to
to go forwards and on that note the
biggest problem I have which maybe some
of you might be able to help me with is
its funding so I've been lucky finding
by the Raspberry Pi foundation for last
five years but they've decided to move
on I mean I'm very generally very lucky
to have had that funding so far but I'm
stuck now and so if I want to keep this
software free which I want to write
because amazing things can happen
finland's and a bus to Africa and taught
2,000 students predominately women how
to code using sonic PI and that was a
beautiful thing to see and I went and
met 12 other delegates from 12 different
countries in Africa who or giving me
high-fives and hugs and that wouldn't
have happened if the software costs
money it's because it's free people are
able to take it and do amazing things
with it the problem is that for some
reason
we live in a world where companies are
making lots of money from products which
are expensive we don't seem to in our
society at least to value free things
how is that how is it we don't value
free things which are free to reproduce
like it doesn't make any sense of it to
me those things should be the most value
for valuable things like it's an amazing
thing to be able to have something the
issues give freely to everybody if
people can freely use yet somehow a
societal wise we don't value that at all
so it's incredibly hard for me to
continue doing that so I'm trying to
raise money so if anyone has an
organisation's looking to spend money
positively especially when we're talking
about impacts and diversity and teaching
children and adults and everybody had a
code and this is an interesting place to
potentially consider using your funds
but also if your individual developers
then there's this patreon thing which I
would really recommend you're
considering giving me some donations for
I've get $1,000 a month which is
brilliance but is that enough for a
salary that's the question right so if
you think about what you earn
individually it's going to be a lot more
than what I earn for starters and I not
ask you that much so figuring out how to
actually figure out how do we actually
get people like myself and I think
there's lots of interesting people who
could really benefit from being able to
use their skills to make the world a
better place and figure out patreon
maybe in one answer is part of the
answer possibly but it's not the whole
answer but ways for us to share our
wealth in a way that allow people to
have the joys of this but with code
right and all the other aspects we can
take code to as well so that's really
the general general gist of what I'm
trying to say does it make sense is it
interesting I've got no idea
I don't know I'm running out of time I
think I think I'm probably out five
minutes left I think probably questions
is a good point of this point your
questions or have I bored you all to
silence yes
are there any interface points so yes
the the major interface point with the
things like this is MIDI and sonic PI
support to MIDI outs a very well timed
through the Erlang scheduler so you can
send MIDI on all channels we have a
whole if I type in MIDI there's all the
different MIDI functionalities MIDI
channels are local pressures all that
stuff's all there so you could send any
of the MIDI messages to any of the
things.when by default MIDI will send to
all devices connected but you can send
it on channel basis or whatever basis
you want yes and then there's also
something called open sound control
which so MIDI goes vilest meanings are
weird things like it predates most
operating systems for all operating
systems pretty much and so it's there
it's one of the few things where you can
actually connect a device and have
chrome talk to it because it's an
operating system but this thing but it's
has limitations so there it has seven
bits for data so you have a 127
different value points for a
potentiometer which is not enough so you
can hear that group unless you smooth
over it and so you want something with a
bit more than hundred twenty seven
different data points
it's like 32 bits would be a bit better
than seven bits or 64 bits is ridiculous
mess
so there's dingle open sound control
which will actually send float values
over the network and we support that as
well so if you want to talk to other
programs get data in and out between
sonic PI and processing or other
visualization systems oprah's and
controllers are a good solution as well
yeah and both of those run through the
Erlang scheduler so they're extremely
well times and they work with all the
time system built in it's all the
synchronization stuff just works yes
yes so there's that weird circle at top
that's you that's you record button if I
press that it's now recording clay 70
recorded my note and press record again
asked me to save it as a WAV file so I
can save anything as well file this
actually I though that you might think
that's exciting I think this is rubbish
I think I'm much more excited by the
stuff we haven't done yet which is to be
able to export this as a data structure
of all the events with a time basis such
that you don't have to have a WAV file
you can just have a list of all the
events that happened and play that back
and that will happen soon yes I'm almost
there but yes you can certainly record
it like this and you can also record a
multiple channels and send multiple
channels out if you have multiple sound
card with the fancy setup as well more
questions yeah yes yeah I mean so I
first thing I introduced it was a notion
of a thread and I called it in thread
because I wanted to be able to hit stop
button and kill the audio and in Ruby if
you create threads then you they just
get crated and you have no handle to
them unless you manage the handles so I
had I handle all the whole ancestry of
all the threads which are created from
the DSL so when I hit stop I can
traverse that tree and kill them all and
then I want to be able to modify the
code live and it was just I had it in
threads and had a function I was doing
the both at the same time just seemed
too complex to teach her a 10 year old
child so this is an example where I was
able to technically do something but I
wasn't able to express it to a 10 year
old child so then I modify the syntax
such that I could do both and that's
what live loop is yep
that's a good question can't multiple
people play over network not well so yes
now with the open sound control stuff
you have two bit of your plumbing
yourself so you have to send us messages
to it so you can send like yous ask you
say where you like it to go to and which
port you would like to go to I think I
say ask foo is that going to me
let's port my list into four five seven
is it listen to report maybe I've turned
it off as rashi but yeah this will send
this was hopefully going to loop back
but you could say message there any any
arbitrary machine and port number and
you can also receive them as well they
just they appear like the MIDI events
down here so all the external events
come through the same system which you
can Pat match and time on so that's one
way of doing it but I am working on
ability to do live jamming together so
that we can sit in different cities and
pre play music at the same time and
having the deterministic part of the
system there allows me to be quite
confident that we're going to be hearing
the same things which is I think it's
quite unusual for these ecosystems yeah
any more questions no more questions
so that who you thinks they might
download the tonight fabulous and please
play with it and more importantly who
thinks they might show up with their
friends who's got friends right good
should leave stare at their friend
because programming is not just for
programmers it's not just for business
it's for everybody to some extent just
like sports is for everybody and we
should really try to use our skills to
share that joy with others as much as we
possibly can because then we'll be able
to go to parties and have conversations
about programming and that would be
great thank you very much
[Applause]